Let's get ready for the Tory Bird show.
I had a fitting the night before
to make sure that my outfit fit right.
A few hours before my clown team got there,
my outfit got delivered,
and I laid everything out. And then
this is where stuff started to get a little hectic.
Everyone arrived.
We got started on hair and makeup immediately.
To me, is the most relaxing part.
At this point,
we were running late,
so we needed to hurry
and get all the finishing touches done.
I got dressed
and then needed to decide what earring to wear.
I made the team vote,
and everyone voted for the bigger ones,
so that's what we went.
Then we got downstairs and got into the car.
I started cracking up when I saw my name
flashing in the driver's window.
Once we arrived at the show,
we found our seats
and the show was starting,
so I'm glad we made it right on time.
All the silhouettes and the fabrics were so beautiful.
I loved all of the coats and the way they moved.
I loved so many of the pieces,
and I cannot wait
have some of them in my closet.
Especially that brown,
sparkly coat.
I can't stop thinking about it.
And then after the show,
I got to catch up with a lot of people
I usually don't get to see.
Since we were rushing in to get seated,
we did all of the pictures
and Interviews after the show
and then it was time to head back to the hotel.